today's date is called from
javascript harvey act and well we are going to go
deeper into why this
name was mentioned although suddenly you
are already including the reason that it was
then we tell a story because it is
a good way to explain why
once upon a time  a developer there in
2020 like this in pandemic mode as we are
today that well he wanted to learn
javascript
and well then he said or that he was already
with a little bit of html with a little bit of
css and let's continue now if in the world of
programming  strictly said and we go
not outside and we learn a little about
variables we learn a little about
how the data is that the strict
polyana cetera then we do in its
first with only later we already print
some data and this and this text
we already put it inside  the
incentive screen the real hackers because it
is about getting an alert window
as we see there on line 3 well past
this what we do in 2020 is let's
go
or  Let's go to a framework or anything or
anything, it's probably not your
case, but many times the stay to
come has already been to build the
interfaces or make projects already in
production quality, because it makes us
get to this point faster and to the
wing  that really everyone is
talking about I don't think we are in an area
and in a circle where we learn a
lot about language and very important things and
more like accessibility etc. but
there are a lot of where because the job
requires you to go directly to this
kind of  we know libraries tools
etcetera then we have arrived at rybak and
you say ok well chivas don't think
hello world after installing the no
james and there you can go pm work pm
install want here well we have this
let's go now I want to do good people
let's continue with the documentation
we start we realize that a component is created
I don't know if we want to look
we wanted to go to the practical part so we
didn't read that I would like that  it does
it declaratively instead of imperatively
but hey there we are making
things work we have a
component we are rendering everything
turn step number 2
let's make it more dynamic let's go
update this state everything is good it
seems that this works although
however already  It's already happened I think that the one from the pool
to the world at this point in which you have already
created a component and rendered it
This component is already being updated
The component is declarative instead of
imperative as it only does these
things because it
begins to have background knowledge
here the more you add to these, the
more debt you are
obtaining from what things you are
doing empirically, things that you
are really understanding where the road is going
and perhaps that is where the idea of why this
alk is born goes because many times we tell
he  world or when we already
consider ourselves very
experienced developers if you first learn the
language and then learn frame  work but it
is very easy to say it difficult to do it and
above all difficult to understand how
this empathy is in 2020 when we
are always guiding you to build
things
and not so much reinforcing all the foundations
let's see let's be honest it's not popular
right there was already a milestone video  from
javascript of 10 people to the video of
riad it is seen by 100 people so that is
also where we are oriented but to
empathize a little more what if
now we tell about once upon a time not in
2020 but in 2010 learning from
javascript
the same story is  I repeated but with
jay query
and if you don't want to reveal your beginnings,
well, that's how it happened to me there in the
area in 2009, 2010 when I was
learning and I wanted to learn basketball
and the industry threw me jake
lakers and well I was a  newbie so
I didn't know where to start one
determined the other where he had
to go I had too many questions and
few answers so to put in
a summary it is in 2  010
we were with jake were and in 2020
we are with diaz cantelar view is to see
what you want to put right in 2030
something will come we will invent ourselves to
forget the language again and I
leave you an open question, perhaps it is the fault
of the developers that we are
creating and optimizing for this it could
be that you are the two creators we have
a little commitment there is part of
the industry that tests
that the jobs tell you hey I want you to
know the angle of the three at the same
time so that you can enter  in your
position as juniors to this job oh
my god the experimental people is impossible
as well you are going to have all that to
start to start but sometimes there are
realities in other realities you can
go today and apply here and I did not put
them here but  At the end of the day, well, these
offers exist and that is why
these doubts also exist, but
whose fault it will be, I have no idea, so
it is the slopes that for the  At the
moment they will have no doubts so for
now we have to be ok with that so
I invite you to debate a little bit in the
chat about the subject see then
now that's how we contribute to this
discussion but with what we do know what it
is  explain javascript so how
about we start
to build a little how it works and
lubián so that we can take
advantage of this about something practical about
something that you if you want to be learning
in some way teach you things about the
language so that you know what parts
actually  what parts are not of the day here
especially young people who
already implement the language because at the end of the day
I have to be written in something we
agree yes of course that if well
then well from the same beginning tutorial
we are going to see that in this hello world
we find two important things that we
distinguish both rial and burton or
my god
wrong
here
ok we continue and see which statutory
we find two important points
riad and rea  ct 2 and inside real
we find that we have the
compose class which is doing stuff out
there we have to use its
render method etcetera that works and we're
actually
shaping this component in the browser
well well since we have four
little things out there for  start
to move forward to explain things we already have
four seeds let's move on
now what if we make this a
component for example of a user that
can be a user like this one not as
if it were like that of a town palette well
the structure of the component of this
user that is the point js would be more
or less in vanilla javascript a little
like that well really your measurements today this
is hard that it is class oriented but
at the same time this that is here is
justin one of the nothing strange is where a
browser  it works it is true because we
have not created compose and in the rest of the
little things that you know from your mind by
context but this talk is
about going out  ing all those little bits and
showing you how they were built and what
kinds of things that you already blame them to
learn from each one of them well
then since we have our
component that we do have it because
we saw it around by staying now
we take care of removing  to our component
to understand a little bit how it is that
this way it has properties how is it that if
eventually it is going to have
but as a base we would have something of this
style where we have a component that
at the end of the day is a class and in
a superficial
[Music] way
we have  two things to
teach both classes and modules and
within the classes we could talk about
object oriented programming
we could talk about it because we put a
constructor why that method is
there because that method is special because
this method cannot be any other
if we want  initialize some new
instance we could talk about instances
although we don't have an example of
this yet and we could talk about pr  properties
because we are already using the
context in which we are creating
this object and also because if we are already
talking about ideas and
particular things of the language in money
we are also seeing the
vance defaults and in turn this component that
is really what  It gives you react that is
being exported, so it also gives us the opportunity
to talk about the techno script modules,
so there are many
little things since, by building
the language a little bit, we can
explain so that they cause a
little more interest in a practical way.
let's return to the user component with
where I already have a little more shape
now we are building it this day
but with vanilla nothing nothing nothing
behind so I am re-implementing it
is not the exact code but but but you will
see what works works believe me have
me  albeit
and the user component
would now look like this since we have compose we
can already import it so we can go back
to ha  talk about the modules but
instead of exporting and importing how to
import a certain bit
of the module, as in this case it is compose
t, then we will explain a little
about the absolute relative paths
and why it has to have a js point and
why  inside when this one wants here it doesn't
necessarily require that point js
explain a little bit why this is pretty
automatically etc etc etc
etc now in this component
vanilla beijing be point j s you're
seeing from line number 6 be
in number 13 a slight variation
I'm not  using js x instead i'm
using something called a literal template
which is a pseudo evolution of a
strict one so you can have
interpolation functions your
dynamic data in apart from features
like the bunk templates
and at the end of the day it does a lot of things
that we do within xavi  to
manipulate complex information that they
have to compose because it is much
simpler l  then we also use
within line number 5
duration and we could also talk
about more specific
programming techniques in all objects such as
inheritance and polymorphism because
line number 3 we are already doing
that inheritance explicitly because
we are extending its being  of component
then the component everything and everything
that it has will also be implemented
in the user air polymorphism because
the poly background the polyforum that
tells us that we could implement the
same methods but in a different way
in the various instances that
we are creating in  this render case
is always particular in all the
components because we are going to render a
user today we are going to render I don't know a
cat of something else in case it were
another real component and well
then it also gives you the opportunity to
talk about its termites that at  end
of the day they are of programming they are of the
language they are of architectures they are of
good practices they are of  to know where the
library starts, the initial finish, something
else and that at the end of the day
is fine, but we could talk about
where the base is, if I already have
with this class compose and I already have my
component now as something that is
placed inside the browser, well
usually inside a cold and you would have
something common index.hu ata that we
also have in this case where I'm going to
import the react render function
although we haven't created it
yet it's not there yet we import the
users component that  we already decided
that it was in the compose folder and
after this we have two things
that we can be talking about first of
selectors that we have in line
number 4 and how this is basically
something that you already allow when you were
doing additional acss you learned
well  I also gave you the chance to
explain it about functions because in the end
render is a quote function that
receives certain parameters and according to that it
does something and then you can  We are going to be
instances because in number 6 I am
creating an instance of my
render component remember that this is fandila
javascript
here there is no hot is x for now
all this this code in theory should
be working in your browser without
removing its absolutely nothing so  I
want you to not see an instance and what
happened to it is instance by parameters are the
properties and that it is an object that has
the name and avatar of my user and
then the second parameter of the
render function of the render method of riad
dom is  where I am going to use that
component is as per the convention of the
library to extract we are already beginning to see
two things the library does not provide us with an
ip there is something like how big it has to
have its parameters and you will see what
you do that was what I went under  that premise I put together
my own function and then my
component has to be able to update
in which to have some type of
structure inside so that it is seen in the
browser that can do this
literal viking text and you have to have
properties so that dynamic values can be put etcet
ra etcetera etcet
ra true well now w
can continue talking about this topic
and we can enter brazil a react
on that could be of action to achie
e the objective of putting my compo
ent in  screen is possible
well well something very simple like
denver function and simply receive
element container ok then container
dot money seven ml equal to element
dot render the function really
returns the playtech text and that
works works works of course I
know that to others  functions of the
functions of the methods because they render
their method of element and then they talk
about the manipulation of don because
we can have and in html we can have
a shame to think about etcetera others or other
modalities to be able to do this and
adapt and choose one for this case
of use and suddenly I can use it in
the future right then
how would this look like  you from liverpool
hello world like that nothing more with
basic things of the image like with a little bit
the elements some functions and you
are simple they are the logs some alert in
something very similar even in something very
similar that is literally the
structure of how a project is started
with network only that now we
do it within search manila not even
in number 3 we are importing our
indec dot js we say that this
module type is so all my taxes and
eventually they work and well my
styles dots is is there I am not
including the inside  of no
component so our ace has life
take this code if you don't believe me and this
code works with data you will ask
leonidas you are cheating because there is
no borrowed and there is no js x or let's
see because that gives us a lot of
little things not to have  there isn't a state or there
isn't a life cycle can't be updated
etcetera etcetera but well this
talk is also about going a little
further and having fun  with this
so how about we start creating our
alternative to these two functionalities
that basically make it cool
that it's with us good
and alternative to js x we have create eleme
t that if you look at the documentation in th
t world we see that there is a check
in which we can remove that hot asx and we
would do something alternative this something
alternative is a quote function that
also comes from the river called
create element that basically
receives the type of element like this
cast case then receives the
properties in this case no  they have
no type of property and then it receives
as a third parameter the content that
this element is going to have, in this case a
hello and the name that you give it, not in
this case or the taylor and that is how
we have to do a good result
this  syntax is a bit more bland javascript
to put it in a certain way so it is
easier to be able to implement so
italy is more didactic to be able to teach
because I remember  since I want to teach you the
language based on something that you already
want to learn, which is bojan
before that, so let's do a little bit of
it, we have a second
functionality of the rival that we are going to
have to have within it within
this module, so let's do a  light
factor of what we have right now if it
would have a blonde
folder it had green in its sd folder recently I will
have react point js iii and the event
point j that day and inside the
real folder an index points j s
this without lying to you is the structure
exactly the same as it has wrinkles
within its facebook repository it
inspires me and of course they have about
20,000 more files but those three exist
as is and basically then
we would have an index from which to export
two functionalities but we would have two
files that would do what  part
what are particularly good in
this case of rial because it would have in its
component and create elements would be this
thing to create these elements  that would
replace our js x in our
case our literal template well
let's continue now if we return to them the
point of js I want it to now start to
have my literal template we are going to change
now for a click element that will have
that same structure this is  it becomes a
little more complex to read because it
is no longer like having an html simply put
the variables
but the structure is much more
understandable at the programming level,
much more problematic and much easier
to be able to teach it,
so well, that element  we create the
life element inside we put the
properties we simply have the
giuseppe class we have a children which
is a special property that receives the
components of react to have an element
inside others and then the
alignment goes exactly the same as
we had  inside our editorial field
now since you're already seeing this we have
to go to our create element so
our create the e  element how it is
done well let's see this
implementation and here you can make it
simple or you can make it sophisticated
depending on how you want to approach
the element but since you see point js
function click element and here we receive
our type of element that can be
our insurance cool celtic the elastic
whatever you want the properties and
then the content that it will have
so I have to do three
things no first I have to create an element
with this type of thing and well here
we have another review
of dom manipulation later  we see that I want to put
the content for that it is very simple
because it is pure text or should I do it
in any case then I had to
have my elements simply text
content and I put the content there is no
complication with the properties
because the properties can have
many  things can be an event it can
be just a property like an
attribute or it can be
[Music]
a chili so that  have an element
within another ok and well here we
have a little reims
methods object methods and
then from the movement of line 11 and
this function that says vertex sector is
what we are going to see in the next slide
so that  they as simply the
different types of properties that
could arrive and in future parties
we would have something that style that is again
within the same element river file
and we have these types of
variants that I told you not on the line
from line 2  line 6 we have the
event support of line 8 of
line 11 of nested children support
line 13 to 15 of line 14 nothing
else is the software support of
normal attributes and line 15
we are basically returning lies the line of
line 13 to 15 is the attributes part
everything is very nice except that it had 5 it
used another function called set
events and on line 10 it used another
function called line del child  ren
because basically again it started to
make this a little bit more functional and to
divide responsibilities because they could
be more complex than complex
but I put them a I have a little bit more
not good so first let's see
the events part so if some kind of
property starts with a you can do
this validation more or less sophisticated
but this works then it told it to
go do events so if they are
activated is what it would do without three
parameters both the event element
and the value and then as simple as
taking  the element at the level and have the
event and then pass that goal is
what we would do when that event has been
launched well now we have the following
case which is the support of children of
line number 10 which is called render
cheever so  it is a property it is
equal to hitler it can also be
validated more easily
if it is julen we are simply going to invoke
the reactor inside
our real element and  yes it is if this
can be many children in a row because I
could make an animation of having three
I don't know for example it is a town of the
base component and inside the children it
can be a lot of laws then
we would fall into the ist of line
number 5 and  Otherwise it would be an
only child so what would we do in line
number 8 and that way or do we make a single
hostage of a render because of the installation
of elements this works and the render
we make we use the same render that
we have in our reactor so that
we use what we had already created so
on that side with this it
works
fine again now let's continue with our state and
life cycle not just a while ago
if you haven't noticed we are
working with classes because they are
more didactic to teach you  how
does all of this work all this day more
and minced instead of just work a
little bit more object oriented ok
so let's go back again to our to
our component that gives us l  The
problems to eventually implement
the solutions and make point to js
we already have compose we have create element
but now our component to require
more things we don't see that out there we are
using this function called
act style this method 7 state
this method 7 state no  it is implemented
in this trial class but it should
be implemented in the component class
we have not implemented it we are going to see
how it is done and in theory what the
bernat s cleaner would do when one puts a
new state that can be an object well
simply  my component is
reloaded and re-rendered as
simple as that and what are we doing in this
case well now we have a
property on line 18 that is a click
so it would fall into registering it
as an event and when it is one click away it will
be executed  and we are going to call our
method hand click that we have the number
8 each one because it receives the event I don't know
anything with the event
but if I am calling online  line number 9
of the function 7 state and I am
simply passing what we had in my
initial state that we have in line number 5
at 7 that starts
in the with a property that
the superior havana has to come to me for example 10
that would be the  number of years it
has ace and the 11 11 12 13 14 15 that
should work but we have
implemented how this is done
right so now let's go to our
laugh js to implement this
remember our component was very very
simple very basic it didn't have  much is a
reality, it is a component, well, very
large, not good, so now we can
continue talking about other concepts of
bullfighting promotions, such
as abstraction and,
first, the fraction in capsule because we have
some methods that are private that
we see in the number  7 when you can
bid within some
[Music]
of some of some field of some
kills are the targets of the
javascript classes that then don't even notice that they are
you can access them directly
you can call a method like
this could be done from state and 7 state
that is implemented in this class
in this case it is to compose well this if
you can call its updater method and well
in this way well  it works and in
an encapsulation way because you
simply never accepted state, that is, you
know what state is going to do to you but
you don't know how it does it and that is
encapsulation and we have private fields
and in this way we
would have a  like, well, that's okay, it's
updated and separates now and we
update our constructor to
also be able to start and interest a
component with properties and also with
a good state now we'll see with the
part of our life cycle
and it's the missing point now  yes, they work well,
establish, update my
component because I don't want it to be
updated, well, I want other types of
signals than knowing that something happened to my
component, something affected it and that
what affected it like, for example, that it was
rendered, like, for example, that it stopped
rendering, like, it was removed or updated
or whatever, well, having a log because it helps me
because because according to that I have
to analyze something else
I just want to put up a blog like  I
put it in this exercise so we have
components new wheel mandiyú plate and
a lot of other life cycle cases
to remember because the
Hispanic component is a method that is
automatically called within a component
when this component is already visible
within the browser  he wilmont happens
much earlier it is simply when
this component is going to be instantiated or I think
it will be initialized since it is not yet
visible in the browser but I already
intend to do this because there it is
called and on youtube take it is for
example  as soon as 87 state and my component is updated
then after it was
used again well I put it there and
there are a few meters of life cycle but
to show u  n button so again
we saw implement them inside our
rival with tj s a bullet bar and again
there we have the methods they are
doing absolutely nothing
we have these types of changes now
we have instead of the render
function directly as we had in  the
previous slide we have the function on
line 21 called build this is the
name of the function I got out of my
sleeve because I can no longer call
learn directly but now I have to
build my component and so I could
call wilmont so that  This method
is called long before executing its
render method, so the render method
is already a little hidden
inside that side and in the same way
when it is going to be updated in the method
of the bitter, which is the method in the
outline 7  we are calling the method
out day that of the number 6 that in turn
were thinking and also after the
command number 9 we are calling the
component or blake to know that it was
updated  my component but now
more things are missing for example in vietnam where
this one is implemented and this is where
the morning comes and we come back and we have to
make a light actor riff to
support all these kinds of things that
would be to put a state and a cycle of
life but within our
[Music]
at least that way it works for
me so at first my reaction is no
longer as simple as simply making
an html link but now in
line number 11 it is being a piece of paper
because it can  how to put an element you
can put elements then to line
number 2
I am seeing like this if I elements a
string I put it directly or if it
is simply an html element it has already
added it
and why because otherwise I
would have to stay  an instance of
that element and in the case of reselling
I have the function of rne from number
5 and depending on what I need I replace
this child or add it in a new way
this function of that method said espe  I
think if something doesn't stop you there are doubts
because we have to go fast
we give him a writer this is
recorded but well the thing is that this
works and it makes me that way
and now yes between the years of travel and if
now it will also happen for example
I don't want to change the life cycle and that a
method listens to which standard or light and
for I am changing from one to the other
oh how beautiful how beautiful how proud
that
is how I feel when I laugh -that it
works and you could no longer ask yourself
this  talk why why isn't it
called because of raccaya the stands
you grab terry here you taught it
javascript
but well with many things they are
questions that will never get an answer
ok well thank you very much
if you want more more of this then visit
my girlfriend she signed up  like on my youtube channel
you had esteban thank you very much